Hey everybody, this is Chris Mason in I want to First just
welcome you to the training library that we've put together for breakthrough
advertising and break through advertising Mastery. And what
I've got pulled up here. This is a slide deck
from one of the the sessions that we do of the
Breakthrough advertising quick start boot camp and I'm not going to go through
this whole slide deck, but I there are a couple that I want to highlight because it
does a really good job of sort of setting the stage for
for what you're about to enter into and specifically
of this topic of mass desire and how how
that desire from the
market actually directs us
as marketers to understand how
our product and or service fits in
and we can actually create our own little market
to sell to and so
I'm gonna shoot just walk through a couple slides with you
real quick, and then I'll run through this.
This the Masters are worksheet and show you
how to use it. So.
The first thing that I like to point out, is that as
you as you study and dive into the text to
break through advertising you'll notice that it's it's actually a process
that has been laid out and it starts with
this idea of the mass desire in the market that
that is marketers. We spend
time researching and understanding what it is that people
really want and then that's part one
and then the next part is well then how do the
specific performances or benefits of
our our products? How does it actually
address those desires and satisfy them and that
sort of naturally leads into
Understanding levels of awareness of what is my market
know about their problem? What do they understand about
solutions that already exist in the
marketplace? And then also looking at Market
sophistication here, which is what are my competitors saying
to my market that I have to be aware of when when
I put my messaging out so, you
know, if you're going into a very highly
competitive space or Niche then
than what you're gonna find is that
you you're going to
have to talk to your Market in a way that
the differentiates you from your your competitors
because you've got a market that is probably pretty
skeptical of the kind of claims that you're making and so there's a
whole process for how to how to do that in the book that will that we'll
talk about in, you know future chapters, but
The idea of desire and where it comes
from is is foundational to understanding how
how the book Works how
bricks are advertising works and one of the
things that Gene says is that it breaks our advertising. It's not a book about
how to be a better copy writer. It is
actually a book that teaches you how to develop these markets
that we're talking about and all starts with understanding Mass desire.
This is one of my favorite lines from
the book. It's right at the very beginning but Mass
desire is something that comes from the market right?
It's not something that you or I create. It's something
that already exists in our job
is to understand it.
And and redirect a portion of it onto our
our product and the visual
that I always like to pull up for this is the the
visual of a river and so if you if you
think about a river it's flowing it's independent of
you or me. We didn't make it flow. It's just
doing its thing and that's really what desire is
like in the market like the desires just there. It's flowing. It's
got an energy and what we're doing is we're
trying to find out where along this River can we
sort of Wade in where it's not too
deep and we want to start to kind of
redirect some of that flow towards our
product. You know, we don't want the we're not looking for the
entire River because that would over overwhelm us, but
just how can we start to redirect some of the this natural flow
towards what we're selling?
And so that's a that's a helpful visual for me. It's been helpful
for other folks who've gone through the boot camp. Hopefully it's
helpful for you. And so with that in
mind what I like to set just
sort of to further set
the stage is we think about like why somebody
buys a product one of the things that we teach in
the boot camp is that
People don't buy the thing that your product
does they buy who your product helps them become so we
all have this idea of the kind of
person that we want to be and we buy a products because we think that those
products will help us be the kind of person that we want
to be. So we're looking for this transformation. And so
as you go through these exercises and you think
about you know, the the mass desire
and the dominant desire of your Market understand that
the underneath those desires people
have
a an image in their mind of the kind of
person they want to be and they spend money.
To to help get them closer to that
image and I I think that that's you know
this idea of like the before and after picture what
it what is the after picture that that
you offer somebody because that's the
thing that they're ultimately going to buy. And so with
that I I wanted us to kind of beyond the
the same page in terms of like just how we
think about where desire comes from
what we're doing as sort of practitioners of
this this craft and and how
we can start to apply the concepts
and break their advertise in our business and that sort
of gets us into this this worksheet here.
This is an actual assignment that we do and in the boot camp.
And there there are a couple I'd give this blank page here,
but there are a couple ways to to start thinking
through how to get below the surface
of what people will tell you. So, you know,
you you can learn from the market you that you
know, it won't the market wants to people in the
market want to lose weight. They want to make money. They want better
relationships. Like these are all sort of big Mass desires
where we find ourselves now
is that so me to many other marketers and
business have sold to those desires that we have
to find.
The motivation underneath those
larger desires and and why
why somebody wants to make more money why somebody wants to
lose weight, you know, what is that was that transformation that
they're looking for? And you know when you marry up
the the why
With with the mass desire you can
start to uncover. What a what a dominant
desire might be in the market and this is what we're really looking
for. Is this this dominant desire that
that has urgency and staying power and scope. These
are three dimensions that that all dominant
desires have and that's what you want
to be.
That's what you want to be fulfilling and
satisfying is a dominant desire. So
a couple ways to start to
to get under the surface here is if
we just take you know sort of this main big desire of
I want to make more money.
In our research as we're you know, looking through Facebook
groups as we're going to Amazon is we're
you know, surveying our list doing interviews with
our customers. We're wanting to
to really understand like the the
motivation behind what somebody wants so
one helpful exercise that we
found is if you think in terms of transformation you
want to do this thing so that
you can what
so I want to make more money so I
can provide a better life for my family.
And already just these the putting
these two together gets you a clearer
picture of of who you're
talking to. It's somebody with a family, right? So
you're getting narrower in in
the in the audience you're talking to but we still
want to go further down the the
rabbit hole so to speak so so here
we say you want to provide a better life for my family. What is
that allow you to do. So keep going to another
layer. So I want to provide a better life for my
family so I can give my kids opportunities. I
didn't have and then you keep going. I want to give my
kids opportunities. I didn't have so I can feel like
I'm a good parent and you kind of keep going on these
layers until you feel like you've you've arrived at at the
heart of what somebody is really wanting
in your Market.
And then what this allows you to do is is you
can sort of marry up these two ideas. So
if you say I want to make more money so that
I can give my kids opportunities. I didn't have well that's
a very specific marketing message that you can can go
out with and in a very specific job,
you're giving your product to communicate how
you solve this problem. And right
here the idea
is that as you go through the sex exercise. I mean
your Market has many different desires, right
and you're you're sure to cataloging all of
them right here and then you're trying to understand like what are
the real reasons that that you
want this transformation, you know, Mr. And
Mrs Prospect and so you would
say, you know, I want to make more money because I want to provide a better life for my family. Well
is this is this an urgent desire like how
urgent is this? Five is most urgent one is
not very urgent how much?
Power does this have is this something that repeats
in the market that
is so, you know, people are always becoming parents. So I want
to make more money so I can provide a better life for my family. That's a
repeatable desire.
And then scope how many people share it and if you
need a refresher on what these mean this comes
straight from the book right there in the first chapter just
so you can reference that. But this is the exercise to
get under the under the surface
and this is just one part. So the next part in the
next worksheet that that will go through is the
product performance worksheet. So you're getting clear on what these
desires and what these motivations are and then you're going
to look at each specific benefit or performance
of your product and sort of match them draw
a line between that performance and the dominant
desire in your Market the other way
to sort of think about desire
and your market and you're really just looking for different ways to
enter into that River if you remember that so we're just trying to
come up with different ways that that we can enter into
the the Market's desire and carve off a little
bit for our product. So this one
is you know, what will they tell you? What what they tell you?
Can't they tell you and shout out
to Michael fisherman for this exercise here? So I
want to make more money. What if somebody is
telling you that I want to make more money. What is the thing that they will tell you
if you're interviewing them they'll tell you, you know, I've had some
success in the past, right? So I I've had
some success making money in the past. What won't
they tell you? I'm not very good
at managing my money. And again the these these answers
they come from your own knowledge
your own experience with the market your own
research. These aren't the things that you're just, you know,
making up pulling out a thin air the work is
to to understand your Market better
than anybody else. That is the unsexy truth.
So what they won't tell you is I'm
not good at managing my money and then what they can't tell you is that
I don't know how to put money to work for
me and a lot of times the things that they can't tell you is is
because they either feel too much shame.
About it and they just won't reason with themselves honestly,
or they just don't have an awareness of this
block or this blind spot in their life and we
can do something similar here. So like, you know, I want to lose 50 pounds
in six months. That's that's a desire in the market, you know,
somebody who wants to achieve this transformation. What will
they tell you? You know, I've tried every diet in the last two years.
And I'm really looking for that, you know magic pill or
course or whatever it is what they tell
you I usually give up halfway through the second month, right
and then what can't they
tell you I have a history of self-sabotaging myself.
And so this is a way to organize again what
the desire is in the market what the underlying
motivations are because when you understand the
motivation's and you can match those up
to the the mass desire
in the market, it changes the the kind
of images you use, you know, so you're up here
a woman or money to provide a better life for my family or give my
kids opportunity that I didn't have
like you're gonna use different images in your ads then
if you're going to somebody who I want
to make more money because you know, so I can show show
the people back home that they never
should have doubted me. You know, we cannot we can have these different types of
motivations for wanting to achieve something
and then here like I said as you
as you start to fill this out with the different Desires in
your Market here the scoring is just a way
for you to to make
to make sure that that you're not
We're going to pursue something that that doesn't
check the right boxes in terms of the dimensions. So what
Gene says in the book is that you want to go after those
desires that have high urgency
have high stay in power and shared by
many many people. In fact, he says they're shared
by millions of people.
So so that that's why these dimensions are important
and I I also
want to just want to point out that like this is this is one component of
of the process. So
if we go back to the process we are just
taking time and we move slowly intentionally.
And this idea of you know slow is smooth
smooth is fast. So what we want to do is want to take
the time to understand the mass desire and and get clear on
the motivations and then we're going to dive in to product
performances.